i think we've now had three generations
of the royal family speaking out
on this issue uh prince william prince
charles and now the queen and of course
the queen speaking out is quite
unprecedented i think look where we are
in relation to the climate summit in
glasgow we we're not anywhere close uh
to the finishing line in terms of the
pledges that countries have made around
the world uh in terms of meeting the
target set by scientists of halving
emissions by 2030 so i think everybody's
speaking out and particularly somebody
like the queen that carries some weight
around the world this is tremendously
important and i think if you if you
match that also with young people who
are speaking out i mean not just you
know famous young people like greta
incredibly important but i'm actually uh
at a school uh climate assembly one and
a half thousand school children uh here
with me talking about climate action
raising their voice i mean we need
everybody's voice to be raised but
particularly those of young people but
the fact that the queen is adding her
voice from her generation i think is
absolutely brilliant news
and it is of course highly unusual to to
get an insight into what the queen is
really thinking she said it's really
irritating when they talk but they don't
do who's she talking about
well
partly i think she's talking about
everybody because you know the rio earth
summit when you know all the world
leaders pledged to take action on
climate change on the nature crisis and
eradicate global poverty actually
happened 30 years ago at the rio earth
summit so basically all the world
leaders are culpable in terms of what
they've done in the past 30 years but of
course there is a big elephant in the
room there's no question about that i
mean china is responsible for more than
a quarter of the world's emissions we
can't make this target work
unless china increases its ambitions so
i think there are a couple of countries
of which china is probably the leader
who really do need to step up to the
plate and increase the level of ambition
that is currently on the table
and as it stands china hasn't submitted
its targets and it's also expected that
president xi won't attend the cop 26
summit without that without china on
board what hopes are there of any real
progress
look obviously it's you know it's
disappointing that some world leaders
are not coming
to glasgow and particularly uh president
xi from china because they really do
need to be in the room they are very
very big players but i think also what
needs to happen at the glasgow summit is
that those countries that are in the
room and particularly the uk is going to
be there president biden from the united
states is going to be there we need to
prove that a just transition can work
that if we invest money in renewable
energy if we invest money in energy
efficiency you know if we for example
can protect the world's rainforest by
having a more plant-based diet and
tackling the industrial meat industry if
we can prove that these things can work
and deliver real change positive change
that really benefits people then i think
we can be an example to the rest of the
world to step up their ambition and
start meeting the targets that
scientists have set us and are really
clear about you know as prince charles
said we're in the last chance saloon
here we're running out of time we've got
to act now and of course prince charles
has been talking about this for a very
long time
well yes and i and i think that you know
i you know prince charles of course you
know was was deemed to be quite
eccentric in terms of some of the views
he had about nature and and climate
change over many decades and of course
now what he's saying is pretty
mainstream and more or less accepted by
every world leader every country and
nearly every human being on the planet
so you know that's the good news in in
the fact that things have shifted
but now it's it's time for words is over
i mean greta said you know too much blah
blah blah and i agree with her you know
action now is really what counts
so no rsvp from china but but some
progress the australian pm scott
morrison has now said he is attending
but but can we expect any real
commitments from australia
well you know scott morrison has
basically been shamed into a attending
and it is really important that he does
attend i mean australia is the second
largest coal exporter in the world after
indonesia it's really critical that
australia gets off coal and invests
heavily in renewable energy i can't
think of any country in the world that's
got more renewable energy resources than
australia and i think we really need to
turn the heat up on scott morris and the
australian prime minister he needs to
come under real pressure from other
world leaders and particularly leaders
from developing countries whose you know
countries will be first at risk and some
of them you know in the pacific in the
indian ocean will disappear
if rich countries like australia don't
step up to the plate